en este vídeo vamos a ver pares de
figuras y analizaremos si son copias a
escala una de la otra
por ejemplo en este diagrama la figura p
es una versión a escala de la figura a
12 en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo hay muchas formas en las que
podemos saber esto una forma es decir
bueno cuál sería el factor de escala así
que vamos a analizar la longitud de cada
uno de los lados
por ejemplo este lado de la figura a
tiene una longitud de tres unidades y
este lado tiene una longitud de una dos
tres cuatro cinco este lado también
tiene una longitud de cinco unidades y
finalmente la longitud de este lado la
podemos conocer usando el teorema de
pitágoras pero todavía no haremos eso
primero comparemos los lados que ya
conocemos con sus lados correspondientes
si empezamos con este lado cuando lo
escalamos su lado correspondiente sería
a este lado y cuál es su longitud bueno
cuando lo escalamos parece ser que es de
5 unidades entonces al pasar de 3 a 5
tenemos que multiplicar por 5 tercios
pero ahora analicemos este lado en la
figura a tiene una longitud de 5 qué
longitud tiene en la figura b bueno aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 sigue siendo de 5
unidades y al pasar de 5 a 5 únicamente
multiplicamos por 1 así que tenemos un
factor de escala diferente porque este
lado es escalado 5 tercios mientras que
la base no tiene escala por lo tanto
podemos decir que estas dos figuras no
son copias a escala veamos otro ejemplo
en este caso la figura p es una versión
a escala de la figura a hauché en el
vídeo y vean si pueden resolver vamos a
hacer el mismo procedimiento aquí ya nos
dan las medidas de los diferentes
por ejemplo este lado mide 2 unidades y
el lado correspondiente en la figura b
mide 6 así que para pasar de 2 a 6
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 y si
analizamos estos dos lados este y este
nuevamente para pasar de 4 a 12
simplemente multiplicamos por 3 hasta
ahora vamos bien pero al pasar de este
lado que mide 6 a su lado
correspondiente que mide 14 aquí lo
multiplicamos por 3 si la figura ve
fuera una copia a escala de la figura
aquí tendríamos que haber multiplicado
por 3 pero seis por tres no es 14 más
bien es 18 por lo tanto la figura p no
es una versión a escala de la figura y
hagamos otro ejemplo nuevamente pause en
el vídeo y vean si la figura ve es una
versión a escala de la figura y hagamos
lo mismo primero vamos a analizar cada
uno de los lados potencialmente
correspondientes
este lado corresponde a este y para
pasar de 4 a 12 multiplicamos por 3 si
ahora analizamos este lado y este
nuevamente para pasar de 4 a 12
multiplicamos por 3 así que hasta ahora
todo va bien y si analizamos este lado y
este nuevamente pasamos de 4 a 12 al
multiplicar por 3 pero ahora analicemos
este lado que corresponde a este y
podemos ver que para pasar de 2.2 a 6.6
también multiplicamos por 3 eso está muy
bien pero vamos a revisar el último lado
nuevamente pasamos de 2.2 a 6.6 así que
multiplicamos por 3 por lo tanto como
todos los lados fueron escala 2 x 3 sin
duda podemos decir que la figura b es
una representación a escala de la figura
y hemos terminado nos vemos en otro
vídeo